peter is with us in Houston hi Peter
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey
thank you for taking my call
sure what's up well I let 28 year old
daughter like just recently moved back
into the house she had a fairly decent
job as a restaurant manager for about
six years making about $70,000 a year
but she didn't put money away
she spent money like crazy she didn't
prepare for any veggies and now she's
been laid off and she's moved back home
because she couldn't afford to pay rent
and she also I found out at about
$26,000 on three separate credit cards
mm-hmm and I believe I've I'm listening
your show in the past I believe that you
said do not use the debt consolidation
companies so I'm just I could take care
of yeah I mean I have a good job and I
could take care of the debt for but I
don't just want to do that no so I'm
sorry she working that one
it seems back as a waitress at a
restaurant nothing is working
yes what's she making approximately
about every two weeks about $1,200 not
working much well now I want what I
wanted to do right now I got her to come
back in the house she was very close to
finishing our school degree I've already
got a student loan I'm taking care of
her for that so she's going to go back
to face to school and I told her I
didn't want to working too much
I just wanted to concentrate on the
school but I'm just wondering about this
credit card debt was the best way to go
about it that's why I go about it to
make money and pay it off that's why I
was asking about the job so I mean I was
is she working
she worked four days a week yeah but
four hours a day no she did well some
days yes four days but she she does do
double shifts I know three of those days
on the weekends
it's a low-end restaurant then because
our tips are lousy yeah it's he Carabas
Wow okay um well I mean I work I don't
know what you did when you're in college
but I work 40 to 60 hours a week and got
through in four years and this kid has a
problem I mean she's got 26,000 not a
problem she's the good news is she's got
no overhead so everything she makes can
go towards the debt two thousand dollars
a month would clear the debt in two in
one year will over one year I he's
already behind on one card and getting
behind on the other two yeah why cuz
she's not making enough money Yeah right
yeah twelve hundred dollars though out
at least maintain the cards she's still
spending money isn't she
well not currently because she has
nothing to spend now well I mean where's
the $1,200 going well this all just
happened so she just he had to catch up
on a rent where she was living so she
her last check went there okay
all right so she's just getting squared
around that alright good so she's not
behind because of the situation going
forward she's behind it because of the
past so she can get corrected here's the
thing let's just do simple math 26,000
divided by 2 is 13 months I want to make
I want to work enough to make $2,000 a
month and you're covering her her room
and board and you're covering her school
yes and she can work enough to do that
and get their school she has two years
left now she has less than a year to
finish the school oh great great so she
could get her degree and be debt-free at
the same time yeah that's what she
should do so you don't recommend just
letting the cards die and then you try
to negotiate with him uh no no I
recommend she pays them off dad okay had
your daughter's 28th she made $70,000 a
year she pissed it all away she needs to
work her butt off and clean this mess up
that's the best gift you can give her
dad
okay let them let the chips fall my man
don't rescue her you're helping her you
gave her a safety net don't give her a
hammock let her clean it up yeah you got
the stuff you love your daughter and
daddies and daughters I got two
daughters too I get it I know how it is
but dude let this girl grow a backbone
in this process this is her this is her
time this is her moment her defining
moment in her millennial years and she
can do this put it on her let her feel
the weight of it it's good for her it's
good for her it was good for you
it was good for me it will give her
confidence going forward it'll be good
it's a good thing
you're a good man Peter you love your
daughter well let her feel the pain hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]